TO OUR FANS BACK IN ARIZONA,
MANY OF WHO ARE WATCHING US AT
WILD HORSE PASS CASINO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUARTER
CENTURY OF SUPPORT, FOR OUR
CORPORATE AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERINGS THANK YOU FOR BEING
PART OF THE PACK.
>> WE THANK YOU FOR WEBBING US
INTO YOUR FAMILY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PLAYING IN TEMPE,
ARIZONA AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR PARTNERSHIP AND BUILDING AN
ICONIC SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT
DISTRICT.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE RGM, BILL ARMSTRONG TO
MAKE OUR SELECTION.
>> ARIZONA SELECTS FROM THE U.S.
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMME
LOGAN COOLEY.
[ Cheering ]
>> WELL, THERE IT IS.
>> YOU LOVE THIS PLAYER.
FOR BEING AN ELITE SCORER.
>> AN OUTSTANDING DEVELOPER.
THROUGH MINNESOTA.
I THINK THE BIGGEST THING IS
HE'S GOING TO MAKE IT FUN TO GO
TO GAMES IN ARIZONA.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT.
>> David: 11:30 SEND IT DOWN TO
JEFF.
>> AT TRADE DEADLINE THEY PICKED
UP JACK McBAIN COMING FROM THE
MINNESOTA WILD ESTIMATE COMES IN
FROM WINNIPEG AND LITTLEFIELD
BUT THEY DID MEET MORE DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
THEY TOOK GUN HER THE ALSO TO
JOSH DOAN AND SHANE DOAN.
>> THEY HAVE A PROSPECT FROM THE
BLUE LINE.
PLAYED 20 GAMES FOR THE COYOTES.
THIS IS WHAT ARIZONA NEEDS.
HE SATISFIES TWO NEEDS.
CENTRE POSITION AND SXIETING AS
WELL.
>> JEFF, THE WORD IS THIS IS A
GUY WHO WENT FROM A BOY TO A MAN
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
TALK TO SOME OF THE TRAINERS.
THEY FEEL THEY DON'T KNOW LOGAN
COOLEY VERY WELL.
ANY TIME THEY WENT TO HIM FOR
COACHING FOR TECHNIQUE OR FORM
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE GYM HE
LEARNED RIGHT AWAY.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO TALK TO HIM
AGAIN AND VERY MUCH THE SAME
CASE ON THE ICE.
HE IS A QUICK LEARNER SO NOT
ONLY ARE ARIZONA GETTING A VERY
TALENTED PLAYER, A BRIGHT ONE AS
WELL.
DAVID?
>> ALL RIGHT, SO THERE HE IS.
AGAIN EVERYONE USES THE SAME
WORDS.
DYNAMIC.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE MINDED IF HE
WENT FIRST OVERALL.
HE'S THAT GOOD.
ARIZONA HAS THE FIRST OF 10
PICKS.
THE BIG STORYLINE.
THIS GUY EXCEPTIONAL STATUS AND
EXCEPTIONAL PLAYER.
CHL ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AS A
16-YEAR-OLD AND HE'S STILL
WAITING.
YOUR THOUGHTS HERE, SAM.
>> IT'S FASCINATING.
YOU CAN SEE SHANE HE'S A LITTLE
RATTLED BY WHAT'S HAPPENED TOO.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT HAS ALREADY
STARTED TO IGNITE HIS FIRE TO
PREPARE FOR THE